Vous avez déjà vu un chat de Schrödinger,
vous ? Un chat qui serait à la fois mort
et vivant ? Moi jamais. Est-ce que ça existe
vraiment ? Pourquoi on en parle si en voit
jamais ? Eh bien aujourd’hui, on va essayer
de comprendre ce mystère.
Une des caractéristiques emblématiques de
la mécanique quantique, c’est ce qu’on
appelle le principe de superposition. Ce principe
nous dit qu’un objet quantique peut parfois
se trouver dans un état qui est une superposition
de plusieurs états classiques. Par un exemple
une particule peut se trouver ici, ou là,
ou bien dans une superposition de ces deux
possibilités.
Le principe de superposition est quelque chose
qui choque notre intuition, et on le voit
très bien si on essaye de l’appliquer à
des objets macroscopiques, de notre quotidien.
Et on illustre souvent cette difficulté en
invoquant le fameux chat de Schrödinger.
Le chat de Schrödinger, c’est un chat qui
suite à une expérience tordue se retrouverait
supposément «à la fois» mort et vivant.
Sauf qu’on n’en croise jamais dans la
rue des chats de Schrödinger. Et manifestement
personne n’a jamais réussi à en fabriquer
un.
Si effectivement le principe de superposition
quantique est correct, pourquoi dans notre
vie quotidienne on n’observe jamais rien
qui soit dans un état superposé ? Ni les
chats, ni les trombones, ni les cailloux.
Eh bien dans cette vidéo on se demander pourquoi
on ne voit jamais de chats en superposition.
Et vous allez voir que la question, et la
réponse, sont plus subtiles qu’il n’y
parait. Et pour cela on va parler de décohérence
quantique, et de pourquoi les chats ne font
pas d’interférences.
[jingle]
Avant d’aller embêter de pauvres chats,
revenons d’abord sur la notion de superposition
dans le cas de simples particules, comme des
électrons. Pour prendre un exemple concret,
considérons cette propriété des électrons
qu’on appelle leur spin.
Le spin des électrons c’est très pratique,
car il n’a que deux valeurs possibles, qu’on
va noter +1 et -1. On a donc seulement deux
cas à considérer, ce qui simplifie pas mal
les raisonnements. Et puis ça fait une bonne
analogie pour les deux états mort et vivant
d’un chat.
Mais attention, quand je dis que le spin des
électrons n’a que deux valeurs possibles,
ça veut dire concrètement que si j’ai
des électrons, et que je mesure leur spin,
eh bien le résultat de la mesure ne pourra
être que +1 ou -1.
[MESURE En pratique si on imagine qu’on
dispose d’un appareil qui mesure le spin
d’une particule, n’importe quelle particule,
quand on y envoie spécifiquement des électrons,
on constate que la réponse affichée par
l’appareil sera toujours soit +1, soit -1,
mais jamais autre chose.]
Maintenant, ce qu’affirme le principe de
superposition quantique, c’est qu’il est
possible d’envisager des électrons qui
soient dans superposition des deux possibilités.
A la fois +1 et -1 en quelque sorte. Pour
décrire cette situation, on doit utiliser
une notation spéciale pour désigner les
différents états possibles de l’électron.
[KETS L’état de spin +1 on va le noter
avec ce symbole là. On écrit +1 entre une
barre et un croche, c’est la notation conventionnelle
en mécanique quantique. L’état de spin
-1, on va le désigner avec ce symbole ci.
Et pour décrire un état qui serait une superposition
des deux, on va noter ça comme une somme
des deux symboles. C’est la façon qu’on
utilise en mécanique quantique pour désigner
cet état superposé.]
Mais ce qui est bizarre avec cette idée de
superposition, c’est que, je vous l’ai
dit tout à l’heure l’appareil de mesure
du spin, lui, réponds toujours soit -1, soit
+1. Il pourrait très bien mesurer d’autres
valeurs, mais quand un électron le traverse,
c’est -1 ou +1.
En particulier avec des électrons l’appareil
n’affiche jamais zéro, et il ne répond
jamais non plus «c’est une superposition».
Comment ça se fait ?
[BORN Eh bien ce que nous disent les principes
de la mécanique quantique, c’est que si
on a un électron dans état qui est une telle
superposition des deux possibilités, alors
une mesure donnera soit +1, soit -1 avec 50%
de probabilité.
Ca veut dire que si on fait la mesure plein
de fois sur plein d’électrons qui sont
tous dans l’état superposé, statistiquement
on obtiendra 50% de «+1» et 50% de «-1».
Un point important ici, c’est que quand
on considère des états superposés, on n’est
pas obligé de faire une superposition équitable
des deux possibilités. On peut de façon
générale mettre des proportions dans les
états que l’on superpose, comme dans une
recette de cuisine.
Pour noter ces états, on ajoute simplement
des coefficients devant les symboles. Et ces
coefficients vont avoir un impact sur les
probabilités lors de la mesure. Si le coefficient
pour +1 est plus élevé que celui pour -1,
comme ici, on aura de plus de chances trouver
+1 lors de la mesure. On en reparlera.]
Donc si on résume, la mécanique quantique
nous dit d’un côté que les objets quantiques
peuvent se trouver dans des superpositions
d’états classiques. Mais de l’autre,
que quand on fait des expériences, on ne
mesure jamais directement ces superpositions.
On trouve toujours l’une ou l’autre des
possibilités, avec une certaine probabilité
qui dépend des proportions dans la superposition.
Et en fait, si vous prenez juste ces principes,
vous voyez que ça règle la question du chat
de Schrödinger. Regarder un chat pour savoir
s’il est mort ou vivant, c’est mesurer
son état. Et la mécanique quantique nous
dit que de toute façon quand on mesure quelque
chose, la réponse est toujours bien déterminée.
Donc il n’y a rien d’étonnant à ce que,
quand on observe un chat, on trouve toujours
qu’il est soit mort, soit vivant. Il ne
nous apparait jamais en superposition, et
c’est bien normal. Donc il n’y a aucun
problème à ne pas observer de chats de Schrödinger.
Fin de la vidéo ?
Sauf que là, vous vous dites peut-être qu’il
y a une arnaque : la mécanique quantique
nous demande d’admettre qu’il puisse y
avoir des états superposés, pourquoi pas.
Mais en même temps, elle nous dit qu’on
on ne pourra jamais les observer ! Qu’est-ce
qui nous prouve que toute cette histoire de
superposition, c’est pas une vaste entourloupe.
Pourquoi on devrait introduire cette notion
totalement contre-intuitive, alors que toute
façon on ne peut jamais les voir, les superpositions.
Ca se trouve ça n’existe pas. Qu’est-ce
qui nous prouve que cette notion et ce principe
de superposition sont pertinents ?
Eh bien ce sont notamment les phénomènes
d’interférences. Ce sont eux qui nous poussent
à devoir envisager et accepter la notion
de superposition quantique. Prenez la fameuse
expérience des fentes d’Young, quand on
la réalise par exemple avec des électrons.
[YOUNG J’en avais parlé dans ma vidéo
sur le sujet. Dans cette expérience on tire
des électrons sur un écran percé de deux
fentes, et on détecte derrière les points
d’impact des électrons qui ont traversé.
Cette expérience est fondamentale car ses
résultats sont impossibles à expliquer si
on suppose que chaque électron passe simplement
par l’une ou l’autre des deux fentes.
Je vous renvoie à la vidéo pour les détails.
Mais ce qu’on constate, c’est que si chaque
électron passait seulement par l’une ou
l’autre des fentes, on s’attendrait simplement
à détecter deux tâches.
Or on voit apparaitre progressivement cette
figure d’interférences. Et une des façon
de l’expliquer, c’est d’imaginer que
chaque électron puisse en quelque sorte passer
par les deux fentes à la fois. Comme s’il
était dans un état superposé.]
Alors notez bien que dans cette expérience,
on n’observe jamais UN électron qui soit
spécifiquement dans un état superposé.
On ne voit jamais aucun électron passer par
les deux chemins à la fois. C’est juste
l’accumulation statistique de tous les résultats
qui fait apparaitre des interférences, et
nous pousse à considérer l’idée de superposition.
Donc si on en revient à notre chat de Schrödinger,
si ça existait comme animal, on comprend
que jamais on ne s’attendrait à en observer
un directement, un qui soit visiblement dans
un état superposé. La seule chose qui pourrait
éventuellement trahir la nature superposée
des chats de Schrödinger, ce serait de pouvoir
faire des interférences avec !
Alors stop, avant que vous alliez chercher
un canon pour balancer des chats sur un mur
percé de deux fentes, il faut qu’on précise
ce qu’on entend par «faire des interférences».
Initialement je vous ai parlé d’électrons
dont on allait considérer des états superposés
de spin, une superposition de +1 et -1. Et
là, avec les fentes d’Young, je vous ai
parlé d’électrons qui passaient par deux
fentes à la fois. Vous avez peut-être noté
que c’est pas du tout le même genre de
superposition.
Dans mon cas je superpose le spin, mais dans
l’expérience des fentes d’Young, on superpose
la position ou la trajectoire des électrons.
Donc les fentes d’Young c’est bien, mais
ça ne prouve rien du tout sur l’existence
ou pas d’états superposés pour le spin.
Pourquoi cette seule expérience nous pousserait
à superposer tout et n’importe quoi ?
Eh bien on va voir qu’en fait la notion
d’interférence est quelque chose de très
générique, qu’on peut retrouver partout
et qui va bien au-delà de l’expérience
des fentes d’Young. Et même avec des systèmes
simples comme le spin des électrons, on peut
réaliser des interférences, qui justifient
de devoir parler de superpositions.
Pour comprendre ça, on va imaginer qu’on
est dans un laboratoire à faire des expériences
avec des électrons, et on va essayer de comprendre
ce qu’il se passe.
[jingle]
[MESURE Imaginez que dans votre labo, vous
ayez une machine à produire des électrons
à la chaîne, comme ça, et que cette machine
dispose de 3 réglages possible. On peut les
sélectionner avec un bouton : il y a un réglage
«-1», un réglage «+1»et un
réglage où c’est mystérieusement écrit
«superposition».
Supposons que dans le labo vous ayez aussi
un appareil à mesurer le spin des particules,
et que vous testiez chacun des 3 réglages
de la machine en envoyant plein d’électrons
et en collectant les valeurs que vous mesurez.
Quand la machine à électrons est sur le
réglage -1, vous remarquez alors que le spin
mesuré est toujours -1, dans 100% des cas.
De même quand elle est sur +1, vous trouvez
toujours un spin mesuré +1. Jusqu’ici tout
va bien.
Et ensuite quand vous mettez la machine sur
le réglage qui s’appelle «superposition»,
et que vous faites plein de mesures, vous
constatez qu’environ 50% des électrons
qui sortent de la machine seront mesurés
avec un spin +1, et 50% avec un spin -1.
L’attitude naturelle face à ce résultat,
ce serait de dire que, manifestement, la machine
émet des électrons dont environ la moitié
ont dès le départ un spin +1, et l’autre
moitié un spin -1. Et si c’était juste
ça, on n’aurait pas de superpositions.
Pas d’électron qui serait à la fois l’un
et l’autre. Non chaque électron serait
juste dès le début soit +1, soit -1.
Techniquement c’est ce qu’on appellerait
un mélange statistique. Et avec juste ces
résultats là pour l’expérience, ça semble
complètement plausible comme possibilité.
Pourquoi aller parler de superpositions, un
truc qu’on a jamais vu, alors que tout s’explique
très bien avec un simple mélange statistique
d’électrons qui seraient soit -1, soit
+1 ?]
Eh bien imaginez qu’à ce moment là le
prof de mécanique quantique débarque dans
le labo, et vous affirme que non, quand on
est sur le réglage «superposition»,
ça n’est pas un mélange statistique. Ce
sont vraiment des électrons qui sont tous
identiques, et tous dans un état superposé.
Et pour en convaincre, il vous propose de
faire des interférences avec.
[INTERFERO Il va alors vous chercher un nouvel
appareil. C’est une sorte de cerceau, à
travers lequel les électrons peuvent passer,
et il vous dit que ça s’appelle un interféromètre.
Et que c’est grâce à lui qu’on va démontrer
qu’on n’a pas affaire à un simple mélange
statistique d’électrons -1 et d’électrons
+1.
Alors vous placez l’interféromètre entre
la machine et l’appareil de mesure de spin,
et vous essayez à nouveau les 3 réglages.
Quand la machine est sur -1, vous constatez
qu’après avoir traversé l’interféromètre,
le spin mesuré est cette fois soit +1, soit
-1 avec 50% de probabilité.
Et pareil quand la machine est réglée sur
+1, on obtient 50/50 de +1 et -1. Manifestement,
il se passe quelque chose, on dirait que l’interféromètre
modifie le spin des électrons.
A priori rien d’extraordinaire dans ces
résultats/ Et à première vue on dirait
simplement qu’il leur affecte un spin aléatoire.
Ça n’aurait rien d’incongru, mais pour
l’instant n’essayons pas de deviner ce
que fait vraiment l’interféromètre, poursuivons
d’abord l’expérience.
Vous mettez ensuite la machine sur le réglage
qui s’appelle «superposition», et
alors là surprise : en sortie de l’interféromètre,
cette fois 100% des électrons ont un spin
+1. Pas une seule fois on obtient -1. Incroyable,
non ?
Réfléchissez bien, c’est impossible à
expliquer en supposant qu’on ait un simple
mélange statistique. Si la machine sortait
moitié d’électrons +1 et moitié d’électrons
-1, on s’attendrait à avoir 50/50 aussi
en sortie de l’interféromètre. Puisque
c’est ce qui se passe à la fois avec les
électrons +1 et les électrons -1. Je vous
laisse y réfléchir si vous n’êtes pas
convaincus.
Je répète, quand la machine produit des
électrons -1, on mesure 50/50 après l’interféromètre.
Quand ce sont des +1, ça fait aussi du 50/50.
Donc si on avait un mélange statistique de
-1 et +1, on devrait aussi avoir du 50/50.
Mais là, on a 100% de spins +1. Ca n’a
aucun sens.
Même sans comprendre exactement ce que fait
ce mystérieux interféromètre, ce résultat
d’expérience est impossible à expliquer
en supposant que chaque électron soit initialement
soit simplement soit dans l’un, soit dans
l’autre état de spin.
Manifestement, quand on est sur le réglage
superposition, la machine ne fait pas un simple
mélange statistique. Et on est ici dans une
situation qui est en fait assez analogue à
celle des fentes d’Young, où on ne pouvait
pas expliquer le résultat qu’on obtenait
en supposant que chaque électron passe soit
par l’une, soit par l’autre des deux fentes.
Ici c’est pareil, le résultat est incompatible
avec l’idée d’un mélange statistique,
manifestement il se passe un truc plus compliqué.]
Ce que je viens de vous décrire ici, ça
n’est pas une expérience imaginaire. On
peut faire des expériences de ce genre dans
un labo, avec différents types de particules
et de propriétés. Et ces expériences, on
les appelle aussi des expériences d’interférence.
Pour comprendre ce qu’il se passe exactement,
je vais vous expliquer ce que fait ce mystérieux
interféromètre, et la façon dont il modifie
les propriétés des électrons. Et pour ça,
on va utiliser le formalisme de la mécanique
quantique que je vous ai déjà introduit
au début.
[ROTATION Voici ce qu’il se passe. Quand
un électron est initialement dans l’état
(+1), l’interféromètre va le transformer
pour le mettre dans l’état superposé (+1)
+ (-1). Et une fois qu’il est dans cet état,
quand on mesure son spin, naturellement on
trouve +1 ou -1 à une chance sur deux.
Quand un électron est initialement dans l’état
(-1), l’interféromètre va cette fois le
mettre dans l’état superposé (+1) MOINS
(-1). Alors petite pause ici.
Ce signe «moins» vous surprend peut-être,
mais il est en fait tout à fait légal. On
l’a dit, en mécanique quantique, quand
on fait des superpositions, on peut mettre
des coefficients devant les états que l’on
superpose.
Et ces coefficients peuvent en fait très
bien être négatifs. En réalité ça peut
même être des nombres complexes mais passons
pour le moment.
Là vous vous dites peut-être, comment est-ce
qu’on calcule les probabilités des deux
possibilités quand on a un signe moins. Est-ce
qu’il y a une probabilité négative ? Eh
bien non, ça ne voudrait rien dire.
En fait le signe ne pose pas de problème,
car dans le formalisme de la mécanique quantique,
pour estimer les probabilités de mesurer
l’une ou l’autre des possibilités, on
ne regarde pas les coefficients eux-même,
mais leur carré.
Désolé, c’est un peu technique mais c’est
important. Dans une superposition, les proportions
respectives des mesures qu’on peut obtenir
sont données par les carrés des coefficients.
Donc reprenons : quand l’électron est initialement
dans l’état (-1), l’interféromètre
le met dans l’état (+1) - (-1). Et j’applique
la règle en prenant le carré, le coefficient
-1 ou +1 c’est pareil.
Et donc si on mesure le spin d’un électron
dans cet état, on aura là aussi 50% de chance
de mesurer +1 et 50% de chances de mesurer
(-1). Pour l’instant ce formalisme explique
exactement les résultats qu’on a obtenu.
Bien maintenant que se passe-t-il quand on
envoie dans l’interféromètre un électron
qui serait initialement dans un état superposé
(+1) + (-1). Eh bien il y a un principe en
mécanique quantique qui dit que les transformations
sont linéaires.
Ca veut dire que pour savoir ce qu’il arrive
à un état superposé, on a le droit d’additionner
les résultats des deux situations prises
séparément. Alors allons-y. J’additionne
les deux cas précédents, et ça fait 2 fois
l’état (+1). Les états (-1) se compensent
et disparaissent.
Ca nous donne donc la réponse à notre question
: une fois passé dans l’interféromètre,
l’état superposé est devenu un état purement
(+1).
Le coefficient 2 ici n’a pas d’importance.
Ce qui compte c’est qu’on n’a maintenant
que du (+1), donc le résultat de la mesure
sera toujours (+1), dans 100% des cas. Et
c’est ça, c’est bien ce qu’on a obtenu
dans notre expérience, et qui semblait impossible
à justifier avec un simple mélange statistique.
Et vous voyez que le formalisme des superpositions
explique complètement ce qu’il se passe.
Les états purs (-1) et (+1) sont transformés
de sorte qu’on obtient ensuite 50/50 quand
on mesure. Mais l’état superposé est transformé
de façon a donner uniquement +1.
Et ce qu’on a là est vraiment un phénomène
d’interférences : on le voit car les deux
composantes de l’état superposé sont affectées
par l’interféromètre, mais dans le résultat
final comme les termes de l’état (-1) se
neutralisent, seul l’état (+1) ressort.
Bien sûr on aurait pu imaginer un interféromètre
différent, par exemple qui réalise l’opération
inverse : on récupèrerait uniquement (-1).
Et il y a encore plein d’autres façon de
faire des interférences, je vous en ai juste
montrée une.]
Dans tous les cas, vous voyez que le fait
d’obtenir ce genre de résultats expérimentaux
montre qu’on n’a pas affaire à un simple
mélange statistique, mais à quelque chose
de plus complexe. Quelque chose qui s’explique
très bien avec une notion d’état superposé.
Ce que ça illustre, c’est que dès qu’on
a un système qui est prétendument dans un
état superposé, on peut se convaincre que
c’est bien le cas en lui appliquant une
transformation réalisant des interférences.
Si c’est bien une superposition, on le verra
car le résultat des interférences sera différent
de celui d’un mélange statistique.
A nouveau, je répète ce point important
: ce genre d’expérience ne prouve pas qu’un
électron en particulier soit dans un état
superposé. Mais ça fait apparaitre les interférences
quand on accumule les résultats de façon
statistique.
Donc imaginons qu’on ait une machine à
fabriquer des chats de Schrödinger, disons
celle imaginée par Schrödinger avec une
boite, une fiole de poison, un marteau et
un atome en désintégration. Quand on regarde
dans la boite, on mesure l’état du chat,
et chaque chat nous apparaitrait toujours
individuellement soit mort, soit vivant.
Mais on pourrait en principe révéler la
superposition en ayant plein de boites avec
des chats, et faisant des interférences avant
d’ouvrir la boite. Alors allons-y, fabriquons
un interféromètre à chats.
Alors oui, mais le hic c’est justement qu’on
n’a jamais réussi. Les expériences d’interférences
qu’on arrive à faire avec des objets suffisamment
petits comme des particules, on n’arrive
jamais à les faire avec des objet macroscopiques.
Mais pourquoi ? Pourquoi le monde macroscopique,
à notre échelle, serait si différent du
monde microscopique ? Où est la limite entre
les deux ? Eh bien ce qui explique que les
interférences disparaissent dans le monde
macroscopique, c’est un phénomène très
important qu’on appelle la décohérence
quantique. Et dont on va parler enfin.
[jingle]
L’idée de base de la décohérence parait
relativement simple : elle nous dit qu’en
principe, il n’y a pas de problème à faire
des interférences avec des objets macroscopiques.
Mais qu’en pratique, ces interférences
sont toujours détruites à cause des interactions
avec l’environnement.
Ce qu’on appelle l’environnement ici,
c’est tout ce qu’il y a autour de notre
dispositif. Tout à l’heure quand j’ai
décrit les interférences avec les électrons,
j’ai supposé qu’il n’y avait rien d’autre
qui allait venir perturber mon expérience.
Mais dans la vraie vie, les objets sur lesquels
on travaille ne sont jamais totalement isolés.
On est dans un bâtiment, il y a tous les
appareils autour, il y a l’air ambiant.
Même si on fait l’expérience dans une
boite sous vide, il y a toujours des atomes
qui trainent, du rayonnement électromagnétique
qui se balade, etc.
Ce que nous dit la théorie de la décohérence,
c’est que toutes ces interactions parasites
tendent à détruire les interférences, et
nous empêchent donc de les mettre en évidence.
Et ce, d’autant plus que les objets sont
gros, composés de plein de particules, et
donc susceptibles de se faire perturber.
Alors juste dit comme ça, c’est une idée
intéressante, mais on n’a absolument rien
justifié. Ca veut dire quoi «détruire
les interférences» ? Pourquoi ça se passerait
comme ça ? Est-ce que ça demande de postuler
des nouveaux principes ?
Eh bien non, justement ce qui est beau, c’est
que la décohérence n’est pas vraiment
une nouvelle théorie : c’est juste une
application des principes de la mécanique
quantique. La décohérence découle de la
mécanique quantique, elle en est une conséquence.
Pour vous le montrer, je vais vous en donner
une illustration simple dans UN cas particulier,
avec nos électrons superposés et notre interféromètre
de tout à l’heure.
[PARASITE Reprenons l’expérience, je rappelle
ce que je disais. On a l’interféromètre
dont on a compris comment il agit : il transforme
l’état +1 en (+1) + (-1), l’état -1
en (+1) - (-1). Et donc l’état superposé
(+1) + (-1) se transforme en 2(+1), ce qui
est un phénomène d’interférence.
Et donc si la machine émet bien des électrons
dans un état superposé plutôt qu’un mélange
statistique, on peut s’en rendre compte
dans les résultats.
Maintenant supposez qu’il y ait une particule
parasite, qui se trouve à proximité sur
le chemin entre la machine et l’interféromètre.
Et supposons que cette particule puisse interagir
avec notre électron quand il passe.]
En vrai si on voulait vraiment modéliser
une situation de décohérence, on ne prendrait
pas une seule particule parasite, on en prendrait
plein. Mais pour faire simple on va n’en
prendre qu’une seule.
[DECOHERENCE Cette particule parasite, on
va supposer que c’est aussi une particule
qui peut être dans une superposition de deux
états. Imaginons que cette particule puisse
être dans un état A, un état B, ou n’importe
quelle superposition des deux.
Maintenant, il nous faut expliquer comment
cette particule va interagir avec notre électron.
Et on va supposer un truc très simple qui
a l’air assez innocent : on imagine que
la particule parasite est initialement dans
un état inconnu, mais qu’au voisinage de
l’électron elle subisse son influence.
Si l’électron est dans l’état -1, elle
se met dans l’état A. Et si l’électron
est dans l’état +1, elle se met dans l’état
B. Simple. Elle ne change rien à l’électron,
elle se contente de se faire influencer par
lui.]
Bien imaginons que l’électron soit initialement
dans l’état superposé, quand il sort de
la machine. Que se passe-t-il pour la particule
parasite ? Eh bien si on veut traiter ça
correctement au niveau quantique, il faut
bien faire attention considérer l’ensemble
des deux particules.
[INTRICATION C’est un peu subtil mais allons-y.
Si on décrit les deux particules ensembles,
classiquement il faudrait considérer 4 possibilités.
L’électron peut être mesuré dans l’état
+1 ou -1, la parasite peut être mesurée
dans l’état A ou B, et donc ça fait 4
combinaisons possibles pour les deux résultats.
-1 et A, +1 et A, -1 et B,, +1 et B. S’il
y a 4 états classiques pour l’ensemble
des deux, ça veut dire qu’un état quantique
peut être général une superposition de
ces 4 possibilités. Donc quand je décris
un état superposé pour l’ensemble des
deux particules, je dois ajouter les 4 états.
Et pour décrire complètement un état superposé
de ce genre, je devrais spécifier les 4 coefficients
à appliquer à chacun des états.]
Bien voyons comment on applique cela à notre
situation.
[DECOHERENCE Donc si j’imagine que mon électron
sort initialement de la machine dans l’état
superposé, après interaction avec la particule
parasite, vu les règles d’interaction,
l’ensemble des deux se retrouve dans l’état
qui est (-1 A) + (+1 B).
A ce stade rien d’exceptionnel, c’est
juste la traduction en état quantique de
la règle d’interaction. Il faut juste se
souvenir de bien décrire les deux particules
ensemble.
Pour ceux qui connaissent, vous aurez peut-être
reconnu là ce qu’on appelle une intrication
entre les deux particules. Leur situation
est maintenant irrémédiablement liée, et
ce même si elles ne sont pas forcément localisées
au même endroit.
Maintenant notre électron continue son chemin
et arrive dans l’interféromètre. Qu’est-ce
qu’il se passe ? Rappelons la règle d’action
de l’interféromètre : on l’a dit : +1
devient (+1) + (-1) et (-1) devient (+1) - (-1).
Et donc notre état complet devient (+1B)
+ (-1B) + (+1 A) - (-1A). Je vous laisse vérifier
que j’ai appliqué correctement l’évolution
que l’interféromètre fait subir à l’électron.
Et enfin, l’électron arrive dans l’appareil
de mesure du spin. Et là j’applique simplement
les règles de la mécanique quantique.
Vous voyez qu’il y a 4 états possibles
au total, tous avec le même coefficient,
le signe - et le signe + jouent le même rôle.
Chacun de ces états a donc 25% de probabilité
de se matérialiser.
Mais comme ma mesure ne porte que sur le spin
de l’électron, je ne regarde que ça, on
voit que la moitié des états possibles conduiront
à une mesure de +1 et l’autre moitié à
-1.
Donc là, la mesure va donner +1 ou -1 à
50/50. Donc ça n’est plus comme tout à
l’heure !Souvenez-vous, avant en sortie
de l’interféromètre je trouvais 50/50
pour les états purs, mais uniquement des
+1 pour l’état superposé, c’était le
phénomène d’interférence.
Or là, pour l’état superposé je suis
cette fois à nouveau à 50/50. Il n’y a
plus d’interférences ! Le résultat de
mesure qu’on obtient est le même que si
on avait un simple mélange statistique au
départ.
Qu’est-ce qu’il s’est passé ? Regardons
à nouveau le détail. Voici l’état que
j’ai en sortie de l’interféromètre (+1B)
+ (-1B) + (+1 A) - (-1A). Tout à l’heure,
je n’avais pas de particule perturbatrice,
donc pas de A ou de B, et les deux termes
(-1) se compensaient, il ne restait plus que
le (+1), c’était ça l’interférence.
Mais là ça n’est plus le cas, ça ne marche
plus. Ma particule parasite s’est intriquée
avec mon électron, ça empêche la compensation
des termes, et ça détruit donc l’effet
d’interférences.
Et je répète : le résultat qu’on obtient
alors est exactement celui qu’on aurait
si au lieu d’une superposition on avait
un simple mélange statistique. Les preuves
de la superposition ont disparu, en quelque
sorte.]
Ce que je vous ai montré là c’est, je
trouve, une des situations les plus simples
et les plus percutantes pour illustrer ce
qu’est la décohérence. On part d’un
objet quantique dans un état superposé,
et placé dans un certain environnement.
A cause de l’interaction entre l’objet
et l’environnement, les deux se retrouvent
intriqués et cette intrication détruit les
interférences qu’on aurait pu espérer
mettre en évidence. Une fois les interférences
détruites, on obtient exactement les mêmes
résultats expérimentaux que si on avait
un simple mélange statistique plutôt qu’une
superposition quantique.
L’interaction avec l’environnement détruit
les effets typiquement quantiques, et fait
émerger un comportement classique, normal,
conforme à notre intuition de tous les jours,
celle qu’on a du monde macroscopique.
Ce que je vous ai détaillé ici, je le rappelle,
c’est un cas extrême de décohérence : il
n’y a qu’une particule parasite qui joue
le rôle de l’environnement. Mais l’interaction
est très forte puisque cette particule s’intrique
totalement avec l’électron.
Ce qu’on peut montrer avec des calculs plus
poussés, c’est qu’on obtient le même
genre de chose si on imagine un environnement
constitué d’un très grand nombre de particules
parasites, et ayant chacune une très faible
interaction avec notre système. Mais le principe
général reste le même : l’intrication
avec l’environnement détruit les interférences.
Alors attention, si vous regardez bien, la
décohérence ne détruit pas les superpositions.
Avant la mesure, la superposition existe toujours
bel et bien, mais elle se trouve en quelque
sorte diluée dans l’environnement. Sauf
que comme on ne mesure pas les particules
de l’environnement, on ne peut plus voir
les interférences qui devraient trahir la
présence de cette superposition.
Un point sur lequel j’insiste : la décohérence
n’ajoute rien de nouveau au formalisme de
la mécanique quantique. C’est vraiment
une simple application des ses principes.
Et on a fini par se rendre compte pourquoi
elle expliquait la difficulté de faire des
interférences avec des objets macroscopiques.
Une application concrète de la théorie de
la décohérence, c’est ce qui concerne
les ordinateurs quantiques. Vous savez peut-être
que ceux-ci reposent précisément sur la
possibilité de manipuler des états superposés
pour réaliser des calculs d’une façon
différente et potentiellement plus efficace.
Ces calculs font intervenir des transformations
qu’on réalise sur les états quantiques,
un peu comme mon interféromètre de tout
à l’heure. Et pour que tout se passe correctement,
il est crucial d’éviter la décohérence
qui casserait les interférences et fausserait
les calculs.
C’est la raison pour laquelle quand vous
voyez un ordinateur quantique, c’est souvent
une grosse machine très isolée et refroidie
à des températures extrêmes. C’est pour
éviter au maximum les perturbations de l’environnement
extérieur qui font décohérer les états
quantiques. Je vous renvoie à mes vidéos
sur le sujet.
Un dernier point, pour faire le lien avec
certaines autres de mes vidéos précédentes
: que nous dit la décohérence sur la fameuse
question des interprétations de la mécanique
quantique ?
Eh bien d’une part, vous l’avez compris,
la décohérence n’est pas une interprétation.
C’est une conséquence des lois de la mécanique
quantique, indépendante de l’interprétation
qu’on choisit.
Ensuite, la décohérence ne résout pas complètement
le problème de la mesure. En effet, elle
n’explique pas pourquoi les mesures donnent
toujours un résultat bien défini, ce qu’on
interprète parfois avec l’idée d’effondrement
de la fonction d’onde.
Toutefois, il faut reconnaitre que la décohérence
jette un éclairage nouveau sur la question
des interprétations, et en particulier elle
semble s’accorder plus naturellement avec
certaines interprétations que d’autres.
Notamment avec l’interprétation d’Everett,
dites des «univers multiples», dont
je vous parlerai dans une prochaine vidéo.
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui, n’oubliez
pas de vous abonner, mettre la cloche. Rejoignez
le serveur Discord pour avoir des nouvelles
fraiches sur mes activités, je vous mets
le lien en description. Et puis je vous dit
à très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo. A
bientôt.